hi I like your shirt oh thank you very
much I appreciate it did you get it like
a thrift store or something oh yeah I
got it from one of my friends no bro
your mustache looks like it's out of a
thrift shop seriously it looks pre-owned
like hi I'm your mechanic and the One's
Gonna did all your kids what can I do
for you
gray makes 1 000 plus tortillas a day I
do make a lot of tortillas every day for
like work or okay you look like a
thousand okay
are you normal no how does she look like
they got me on a date with a nerd who
works at Chipotle that's how I make my
money yeah that's kind of what I do I
grew up eating a lot of Mexican food so
oh really like tortillas all right yeah
yeah and what are you talking about the
Mexican food you talk about Tex-Mex
there's a difference I love Mexican food
yeah what uh I just love quesadillas
that's not Mexican
I love uh queso cheese
queso means cheese
I'm not gonna lie I do like cheese
cheese it makes me think of that picture
of trump eating a big old quesadilla
happy Cinco de Mayo and Mexicans all
over like yo [ __ ] you nerd that [ __ ]
ain't ours no you're hanging out with me
you can get Fresh Tortillas anytime nice
not too big of a fan of tortillas then
yeah oh you're into making tortillas
well here's one tortilla you'll never
get inside of can I get the [ __ ] out of
here she said can I get the [ __ ] up out
of here yeah bro you got a thousand
tortillas to make
hello I'm Abby I'm Cody nice to meet you
Bobby hey Steve
can you show her your feet do you want
me to show your little feet yeah you
want to see my feet I ain't shouting
days [ __ ] smell this
look at him
oh nice
[Music]
why did you reject me oh um
my friend my friend this is a sickness
of the highest order
I'm good how are you good
button hands right there my man came in
like Thanos with the infinity let's go
every gem collected let's go what makes
you horny
sorry what makes you horny I see horny I
don't know this is weird I'm a ass man
is that is that weird to say
wow
[ __ ] wow
[Applause]
actually wait wait wait wait wait in her
defense I could see why she might have
thought that one this dude came in
dressed like Mac Miller
two this man said like you like ass I'm
hearing me it is what it is oh yeah
that's that's probably what yeah
I like it I don't know there's been a
couple of times why I do like ass look
at this and I'm like bro this is a lot
of leg
yes that's a lot of legs no no that's a
lot of legs there's a difference between
ass yeah in Lake yeah the number five I
can appreciate both
well a lot of white dudes like late
Carrick nice to meet you Eric yeah nice
to meet you I have a fact about Julie
she was banned from him
what did you do I was unhinged unhinged
and oh [ __ ]
to anybody that would make too early of
a sexual
would you reject me um I feel like we're
Reviving more than the last girl but
like still kind of wasn't
like he don't like Asian women either
that would be perfect
yo can we just appreciate something what
what is so white dude all of a sudden
the racial comments aren't coming out
everywhere do you notice that
why dude all of a sudden the racial
comments start coming out everything
it's okay to do racial that makes her
like it's okay they were like he's a
black with a long T you think a white
woman got a friend was saying that on
camera
how many times did people come to you
and said I don't see color
how many times
right now it's the same thing that
happening to them they only see they
don't see color they only see white when
white comes out they're like um I don't
see colors me personally I don't see
colors I do see as though yes girl
Jasmine yeah I like your earrings thank
you
Danny hi
I'm gonna oh that's crazy
it was
I the Kraken hat doesn't go with the
sweater
oh
shh oh hell no
good YouTube show me your best club
dancing
oh is that like the recipe oh nope what
is that that's dirty the sturdy yeah
it's reject me okay the dance moves like
I've just
I got secondhand embarrassment I'm not
gonna lie I'm sorry that's okay I
thought that's not a criteria you don't
think it's good you could go out with
someone that don't dance good you know
that right and just not dance with that
person you know what I mean like but I
like dancing you know that you're not
gonna base your life on someone's cap
or their dance moves yeah I'm really
dating if you're dating if we're talking
about dating hi nice to meet you nice to
meet you what kind of vibe are you
looking for I don't know someone who's
move yeah move move move why because
move can you ask him what his turn-ons
are what are your turn-ons
um I think like turn on wise I am big on
like I'm uh My love language is physical
okay so like turn-ons wise I don't know
I it's hard to describe it's one of
those like
I like it when you sit on my face
I like physical touching by physical
touch I mean my face your lips on my
lips and I ain't talking about your
mouth
and imma add
please by you I just like when somebody
kind of does like Words of Affirmation
you know kind of like they're yeah yeah
words of affirmation hey mate you making
my dick hard how's that for me
but in case that wasn't clear you know
what would make it harder if you sit on
my face yeah that where's the
affirmation Hey listen I've been trying
to get my dicks up all night bye
I'm so sorry to pause but we need to
pick something
are you okay oh no they're about to turn
it red and then she gonna hit that
button yeah
do you find Brian attractive
are you asking me no she's not getting a
guy fixing the button
it's truck going you know you got that
going
hey what's up
nice to meet you
part it works
oh y'all finally fixed this [ __ ] bam
thank you bye hello I'm finding you so
attractive and I find you cuter when
you're not here
the face of the radio
your face looks better from the back
fair enough was that you testing it yeah
rejection I feel so bad you like bad
boys yeah I do like bad boys hi they're
they're definitely the guys who give you
all the words of affirmation you need
the bad boys
yeah Brian do you love me just stop
calling me so much no you clingy as [ __ ]
man I'll give you a compliment stop
asking you are clingy as [ __ ] that's
affirmative technically I mean
you like what now I like bad boys what
makes you think I'm a bad boy I didn't
say
that no that's okay what's your name
Rosia what's your name James nice to
meet you nice to meet you
are you a bad boy I'm a wholesome person
how about that you sound so toxic I'm
not toxic at all I'm a wholesome person
yo dead ass okay this is a tip to all
the guys watching if a girl starts
saying yo you a bad person are you a
toxic person like yeah yeah I'm
radioactive Place let's get it popping
baby don't don't try to qualify yourself
don't try to convince her or something
yo is that what you think I am yes and
you look you're into that let's go keep
it pushing do not do this batch no no
I'm good you trust me don't do that [ __ ]
that that will work against you every
single time that or just move on to the
next thing this is just don't disregard
it okay but don't qualify yourself to
somebody you just met that's a walking
elf I really like your earrings that
stuff oh thank you yeah
whoa
that's what I'm saying like Okay Okay
this is something you learn early on
okay when she called you on your [ __ ]
those are [ __ ] tests that's basically
her being like what you got [ __ ] that's
what that is so you either step up or
you change patch stick but what you
don't do is like no no no because
essentially she sees you as beneath her
she gonna buzz you in real life or on
the button as soon as he said wholesome
I'm sorry I don't believe you
you too he likes to smell his dog
oh yeah what do you are you like a pet
person I mean yeah but like what do you
mean
what do you mean I mean yeah but I'm
black
that's so fast bro why are you doing
weird [ __ ] with a dog sometimes like I
don't care who it is out there that's
watching y'all who kiss your dogs on the
mouth
no I just
oh that's weird
it is weird right they to me it is I
love your dog but like you gotta love
them with your tongue
so you know how like if there's someone
you really like you like the smell of
them yes I'm the same with my dog okay
so like you're picking out the shampoos
and stuff on purpose to make sure they
smell good for you or like oh for my own
hair for my heart no for your dog
my friend my friend
my friend you can leave
okay actually you know what I'm ignorant
in regards to pets are you supposed to
shampoo your pet regularly it depends
what kind of pets you got okay it
depends what kind of pets you got if you
got a big ass dog that [ __ ] I'm
gonna end up thinking so if you go out
if you go out there out there with your
dog and then you know yeah there's
wetness outside it might like it's gonna
there's a smell doesn't smell it doesn't
smell what smells about a cat is not the
cat it's the litter and then if you fix
that and then change that and you're
good to that then your cat don't smell
it's the litter box that smell you
understand but if you got a whole ass
dog you need to shampoo the
[ __ ] cause them [ __ ] be
spelling smelling like doll
it's so weird to meet a girl whose
coochie's clean but her cat litter is
dirty that's like there's always one
[ __ ] that's busted
that's unnecessary
what are you talking about girls can't
take care of two [ __ ]
some girls can't even take care of one
because if you're a cat litter now your
[ __ ] smells similar that's a problem
yeah
gonorrhea yeah okay nice to meet you
nice to meet you as well I like your
little fit you got going on here I tried
a little bit but I have a question
how would your ex your most recent one
describe you she would probably say I'm
carrying on the bad side she'd probably
say that she would say I'm controlling
but the only reason why she would say
that is because she uh posts
very explicit pictures on Instagram and
I was like you know I understand that
you're happy with your body and I
support you but at the same time can we
like dollar back just a little bit okay
and she didn't like that
interesting
wow you about to hit the button no I got
scared I swear
he saw that hand flange
I I'm gonna tell you right now
he told his ex can we just die in the
back a little bit
that ain't gonna happen no that's not
how it happened that's how we told it
right now to make this day work your
shout outs to him that's how you're
supposed to do yeah but if we real
honest he probably like man you stopped
being a [ __ ] hoe on IG bro
bro you got your coochie lips out there
oh why you lips in me ain't no reason
why so many [ __ ] got access to your
lips at the same time all right you got
to be scally wagging listen I like your
cheeks I'm kissing your cheeks your
cheeks shouldn't be on IG that's how
that [ __ ] went down it wasn't baby baby
uh somewhere down if you think you're
controlling and they could you die no no
no that [ __ ] didn't go in like
it seems
[Music]
he didn't go ahead baby
you didn't you didn't do that
positioning she's a brick
I don't know why that's so cute I don't
know but good good yeah do you think you
should be interested in going on a
second date
I'd be interested in going on a second
date
I too would be interested in learning a
second game
one more time
you don't press me
ouch
why'd you reject me I don't know I just
couldn't get over the little like that
you're talking about with your ex I kind
of do like to post freely I don't like
anybody to hold me back that was kind of
my issue with my last relationship so as
much as I like everything else in the
conversation and I really wanted it to
work I just don't want to be in another
situation where I feel like I'm held
back at all
I'm really sorry it's cool I get it I
get it you know
how you gonna clown this dude for
talking about oh I'm a big controller
you said you're into bad boys what do
you think a bad boy is if not a little
bit controlling you just sound confused
that's what you asked for no that's like
me saying I'm looking for a bad [ __ ]
and this girl come in with a bit of
cleavage showing and I'm like I like
someone what she's not confused
she's cherry picking what she wants
one ass pick without the other aspect
it's like when people say they wanted
men that opens up but they don't really
want that thing it's not that they're
confused is they don't want the whole
thing they want a little part of it and
not that part of it that's it that's not
confusion it's not confusion
pickiness I disagree this is a sickness
of the highest order she has come here
she has asked for one thing she said
give me a burger it has been given to
her she says I don't want the bun I
wanna excuse me when you are going to
order a baguette always comes with the
bun if you don't want a burger you just
want meat say what the meat
huh it doesn't always come with a bun ah
this one look at this one he's so
open-minded he says gender is not a
thing a burger is a social construct
according to this one eh they are all
engaging in confusion do not listen to
these ones eh if you do you know it's
going to happen you're going to go
outside you're going to see sodomy
everywhere so do everywhere you're going
to see a man he's going to be walking
like this his anus has been ruptured
I'm done I'm finished I will not gaze
upon this sickness anymore
go ahead engage them with your confusion
it's like it's like whenever someone to
take his Burger thing it's like if
someone says they want a burger but they
don't want to get fat they're not
confused they're pink they're picking
not taking accountability of what
they're choosing is that's it you wanna
eat eat all you want but I don't want to
get fat I'm sorry it's just I wanted a
burger but you know it's a fat like one
of the Five Guys burger but the amount
of fat is just a bit too much yeah
whatever get your Five Guys girl anyways
that's besides the point
is what it is not much inside